yeah this Ronnie lipstick will be
testing the new Subaru WRX STI a fresh
version of an old friend he's owned two
from the first generation the subaru WRX
STI has always stood out from the crowd
that starts with a huge rear spoiler and
continues in front with a large air
scoop that supplies the intercooler with
fresh air now Ronnie is going to put
this machine through its paces on the
road official of picant new las lomitas
piece lot of admin and cooking masters
things office classic on
the world's biggest manufacturer of all
wheel drive cars Subaru is best known
for its victories and the world rally
championship or WRC at first one in 1995
with colin mcrae at the wheel of a
Subaru Impreza 555 our all-wheel drive
test car is 4th generation and bears the
name WRX STI
las nubes onething Ronnie is especially
pleased with the new STI steering which
gives him all the feedback from the road
he could want for someone used to
smoother but squishier steering it might
take some getting used to it's extremely
direct ha stop Judith ankle boom glove
is direct the STI is two and a half
litre turbocharged boxer engine produces
221 kilowatts the Japanese rally car
launches from 0 to 100 km/h in just 5.2
seconds OSH busted Ronnie says driving
fun is in the foreground with a new STI
the boxer engine puts out loads of power
that's like vagina vons and scuffed the
engine develops 407 newton meters of
torque at 4000 revs a minute all
courtesy of the big turbocharger the
subaru looks sporty to STI stands for
subaru tecnica international Subarus
house tuner LED headlights and black
18-inch light alloy wheel rims are
standard equipment
even from a distance you can't miss the
big rear spoiler which says this monster
means business a third brake light is
integrated in the diffuser
does a bobble big Ronnie admiringly
calls the WRX STI a rally car for the
road what you might not expect from a
car like this is the roomie trunk has
enough storage space to take supplies
and luggage for the whole family on a
rally weekend and the recent version of
the WRX can indeed be seen at rallies
but this Subaru displays its qualities
on country roads as well the technology
of the new WRX STI isn't much different
from that of the first generation says
Ronnie he can still change the driving
mode or differential by pushing a button
the feature was introduced in 1994 and
Ronnie still likes it feature the
competition will have trouble matching
Subarus level a bang for your buck and
the sports equipment line we tested the
WRX STI costs just over 46,000 euros in
Germany it has an automatically dimming
inside rearview mirror blind spot and
lane change assists and a rain sensor
the interior comes with an audio system
by Parman cardin a backup camera heated
seats and a navigation system
you